hey was geht ab herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge des rolex trader
projektes wir probieren uns heute mit
sportwetten zur rolex hoch zu handeln
nachdem wir uns also schon an einer 800
euro mystery boxun aktienhandel und
annika retailing versucht haben werden
wir jetzt in diesem projekt sportwetten
tatsächlich bin ich immer noch nicht
alle schuhe los geworden die ich für das
nickelprojekt gekauft habe das bedeutet
wir sind bei folgenden betrag aus diesem
grund und weil ich von sportwetten
relativ wenig halte werden wir das nicht
mit unserem kompletten geld machen was
wir gerade zur verfügung haben sondern
mit 1000 euro
was für sportwetten auf jeden fall
reichen sollte denn ich gehe nicht davon
aus dass mit plus machen dieses mal
glaube ich wirklich nicht im endeffekt
habe ich nicht 1000 euro überwiesen
sondern nur 690 weil ich irgendwie nicht
mehr überweisen konnte ich weiß nicht
warum also startet dieses projekt mit
619 ja noch ganz kurz in den letzten
wochen ist hier auf dem kanal ein
bisschen ruhiger geworden ich wollte
einmal mir selber klar werden in welche
richtung der kanal gehen soll
ich war aber nicht untätig auf dem zwei
kanal kamen tägliche uploads also checkt
den link in der video beschreibung
schaut auf dem zwei kanal vorbei für
mehr kommt denn für täglichen content
lasten aber da und checkt die videos aus
aber warum ich glaube dass wir genau bei
diesem projekt kein plus machen werden
obwohl es ja bei anderen super riskanten
projekten auch geklappt hat das erzähle
ich euch gleich erstmal ganz kurz vorweg
also es ist wirklich komplett um
es gibt wahrscheinlich niemanden der
weniger ahnung von sportwetten haben
kann als ich weil die meisten
sportwetten drinnen sicher um fußball
und so weiter wenn es eine sache gibt
für die ich mich in meinem leben noch
nicht eine sekunde interessiert habe
dann ist es fußball das bedeutet wir
werden einfach relativ nüchtern an die
sache heran treten uns die quoten
anschauen irgendwelche kombination
raussuchen und dabei nicht darauf achten
was für sympathien haben wir für welches
team wie gut ist welches team drauf
sondern wir gehen einfach nur nach den
zahlen die uns hingegeben sind
beispielsweise borussia dortmund gegen
vfl wolfsburg wurde von 15 853
die quote sagt uns ja ziemlich genau wie
wahrscheinlich es ist dass welches team
gewinnt und das allerwichtigste bevor
dieses video startet ich behandle öfter
themen bei denen ich sage bitte probiert
das nicht zu hause aus und das meine ich
auch so ich mache diese projekte damit
ihr das nicht mit eurem eigenen geld
ausprobieren müsst und egal wie dieses
projekt wieder ausgeht ich bitte euch
darum macht das nicht zu hause nach ich
mache das auch nicht abseits dieses
videos langfristig verliert ihr es gibt
keinen grund hier probieren sein geld zu
verdienen
ihr seid nicht schlauer als die anderen
ihr wisst nicht mehr über fußball als
die anderen last ist sein packt euer
eigenes geld nicht rein es macht keinen
sinn ich habe mich jetzt gerade hier mal
ein bisschen um geschaut und gesehen das
ist eine wichtige sache zu wissen wenn
man wetten kombiniert also wenn man
jetzt beispielsweise sich hier auf
dortmund setzt und dann hier auf bayern
dann werden die wettquoten nicht addiert
sondern multipliziert das bedeutet man
hat eine viel höhere quote wenn man
mehrere wetten auf einen wettschein tut
ich weiß aber nicht ob das für mich die
erste option ist und ich weiß auch nicht
ob das für irgendjemand eine schlaue
option ist desto mehr spiele man auf die
karte tut desto mehr möglichkeiten gibt
es das irgendeines der spieler nicht
funktioniert genau deswegen gibt es
diesen multiplikator und genau deswegen
funktionieren ganz häufig werden nicht
in diesem fall jetzt aber bei borussia
und bayern bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
dass sie gewinnen ich setze auf diesem
weg 200 euro
keine ahnung ob das keine ahnung ob das
schlau ist ich habe jetzt 50 euro auf
einen 3er kombi wette gesetzt und 200
euro auf eine 2er kombi wette in der
deutschen bundesliga 0 plan wirklich
aber wir schauen vielleicht haben wir
glück und außerdem haben wir noch mehr
tage um möglicherweise unseren negatives
ergebnis auszubauen tag nummer zwei und
freunde wie sollte es anders sein ja wie
sollte es anders sein ich hatte am
ersten tag tatsächlich glück ich muss
das ablesen denn ich kenne die ganzen
team mannschaft nicht atalanta gewinnt 5
gegen eins gegen sassuolo
daneben wird atlético gewinnt 1 2 gegen
allawis und barca gewinnt auswärts mit
einem tor das bedeutet wir haben aus 50
eur 161 gemacht na ja und als ob das
nicht schon glück genug wäre bei dem
spiel von madrid hat man tritt den
treffer der uns diese wetten nur
gewinnen lassen hat in der neunzigsten
minute gemacht also wirklich ein
gebürtiger einstieg für mich die
dreierquote in der 90 minute zu spüren
also ich fühle mich sehr wohl aber das
war natürlich nicht die einzige werte
die wir hatten die zweite wette mit 200
euro einsatz stand er auch noch aus
dortmund und bayern gegen mainz und
wolfsburg deutlich niedrigere quote
deutlich höhere gewinnchancen so haben
es zumindest die quoten vorhergesagt und
trotzdem wurde es wirklich knapp
dortmund hat als erstes mal zweimal
gewonnen super solide kein problem und
dann bayern gegen mainz mit der
niedrigsten quote überhaupt also
eigentlich der sichersten chance zu
bayern zu gewinnen ich wusste nicht mal
dass mainz überhaupt in der ersten liga
spielt
zur halbzeit lagen sie mit zwei toren
vorne 0 zu 2 ist das schrecklich für
mich aus aber was haben die bayern in
der zweiten halbzeit gemacht doch
lewandowski noch ganz entspannte fünf
tore und so läuft 5 zu 2 gewonnen also
wirklich ein sehr stabiler erster tag
für mich 258 euro plus in zwei welten fc
liverpool gewinnt sage ich und darauf
setze ich 200 euro fühlt sich so falsch
und fühlt sich nicht nur falsch sondern
warte auch aber seht selbst das ist
soweit freunde eine genugtuung für alle
die sich gewünscht haben ich habe
verkackt ich habe gestern 200 euro auf
liverpool gesetz tabellen erster im
england also eigentlich überhaupt kein
problem niedrige quote einfach ein
bisschen cash mitnehmen viel rein tun
und quasi in sicheren gewinn haben was
passiert sie haben unheimlich schlecht
gespielt und gegen den tabellenneunten
verloren absolute schande 200 euro weg
das bedeutet wir sind nur noch 58 euro
im plus oder so ich glaube dass einige
von euch sich freuen werden denn endlich
passiert mir auch mal was vielleicht ist
und ich habe nicht nur blöd aber
vielleicht können wir unser glück heute
schon wieder ausbaden ich suche nach wie
vor eher nach so quoten wie tottenham
gegen brentford 152 ich würde mir wieder
irgendein schein zusammen und dann
schauen wir mal andere sportarten sehe
ich mich eigentlich nicht vielleicht
mache ich mal ein super riskanten
scheinriesen multiplikator einfach um
das von gestern wieder auszugleichen mit
der französischen liga wo es heute abend
ziemlich viele spiele in dem moment ist
es mir gar nicht aufgefallen aber es hat
wirklich nur zwei tage gedauert bis sich
solche muster wie ein richtiger spieler
entwickelt hat ich setze geld um einen
verlust vom vortag auszugleichen das ist
wirklich der anfang vom ende und der
anfang der abwärtsspirale
genau so geht das los und genauso sollte
es nicht sein so schoss tag auxerrois
yaki okay es ist fast ein achter quote
das bedeutet wenn wir da 12 eur 50
draufhauen 15.50 versteht ihr was ich
meine
also zwei wettscheine heute abend
gemacht einmal 100 euro drin einmal 25
euro drin eine viererwette eine zweier
wette einmal dort fort um tottenham und
einmal ja kiosks treues und so schoss
wir können wir da nichts tun das glück
liegt nicht mehr in unseren händen ich
gehe jetzt erstmal in den stream da
könnt ihr auch vorbeischauen jeden
dienstag donnerstag und sonntag bin ich
live und dann schauen und hoffen wir
dass daraus etwas wird tag nummer vier
würdet ihr es diesen mann können einen
großen gewinn wird einer sportwette
gemacht zu haben ich ja und wir werden
schauen ob was daraus geworden ist
tatsächlich wirklich aufgeregt denn das
war die verrückteste wette die ich
jemals gemacht habe
der höchste gewinn den wir erzielen
hätte können bis dato ich habe null
davon gesehen und kann natürlich auch
die französische liga in keinster weise
einschätzen genauso wenig wie ich alles
andere einschätzen kann ja wirklich
einfach die besten voraussetzungen die
man sich vorstellen kann der moment der
wahrheit okay nice die 2er kombi wette
haben wir gewonnen da haben wir 100 euro
gesetzt 115 euro gewonnen und die 25
euro wette haben wir verloren
das bedeutet wir haben 90 euro drin
gemacht gestern sehr sehr nice und
tatsächlich oh mein gott es hat nur das
eine spiel nur auf serie gegen seien nur
das spiel hat verhindert dass wir aus 25
euro über 300 gemacht haben nur das eine
spiel ja ansonsten habe ich wieder alles
richtig getippt das eine spiel hat mir
wieder den kompletten schein zerstört
muss ich da noch irgendwas zu sagen ich
lasse das einfach so stehen die andere
wetter hat funktioniert kein problem
90 euro plus dank tag 4 insgesamt sind
wir weil sie nicht wie viel euro und
plus beschauen direkt was heute so geht
manchester united gegen manchester city
mailand gegen juve bilbao gegen
barcelona will gegen ajoie es ist
glücksspiel aber man hat das ist genau
das problem
ja man hat das gefühl man könnte daran
irgendetwas machen aber man packt ein
spiel mehr rein es wird
unwahrscheinlicher
die quote wird besser es fühlt sich an
als könnte man mehr gewinnen dabei
verliert man hat man einfach nur eine
höhere chance zu verlieren und diese
denn denn der erwartungswert ist ja
negativ er bleibt auch negativ egal wie
du wieder etwas rum drehst und so und
das jetzt sind wir am tag 4 in dem
experiment ne und ich bin eigentlich ein
ziemlich rationaler typ aber es nimmt
mich richtig mit weil ich denke okay da
und da habe ich richtig getippt also
gehe ich weiter in diese richtung und
kann damit bestimmen dass das projekt
langfristig gut funktioniert und genau
das ist das problem
das was dann die user monaten ohne
erwartet eine leistung zu sitzen ja wenn
du ja auch das ist ja geht und nicht so
viel geld und ich denke so ok ist es nur
das geld aus dem projekt also kann ich
da auch mal was riskieren aber es ist ja
nicht geld aus dem projekt ist ja geld
was ich verdient habe
egal ob es im projekt ist oder nicht
eigentlich wollte ich dann am abend bei
der wette von neapel paris und lyon
belassen aber ich habe mich jetzt
kurzfristig dazu entschieden doch noch
ein paar auf ein paar spiele mehr
zusetzen und wir fahren jetzt dahin und
schauen uns die spiele an
ich habe die tipps von einem kumpel
bekommen der ein bisschen mehr ahnung
von fußball hat sich zu dem fall schätzt
dann schauen wir gemeinsam und
möglicherweise habe ich ja jetzt mehr
spaß am fußball
ein bisschen money online ist und
vielleicht habe ich noch mehr spaß wenn
wir mehr geld gewinnt endlich wieder
fußball ist christiane vorne das ist der
echte könig vom material wird für mich
die fifa sagt er nicht ja ich sag
ehrlich fußballmacht hundert mal mehr
spaß zu gucken wenn man ihm das alter
aber plötzlich kalt ist nicht für die
scheiße begeistert wie ich gerade eben
schon gesagt habe ich habe null
verbindung zu fußball und jetzt setzt
sich geld und auf einmal bin ich super
emotional bin super krass mit drin der
sport und die teams rücken irgendwer
hintergrund und es geht so ein bisschen
um egoistischen gedanken ich habe geld
da drin also gewinnt besser das team ich
bin für dieses eine team ich habe keinen
es geht nicht mehr irgendwie um fan
liebe oder sonst irgendwas und ich kann
mir vorstellen dass es bei echten
fußballfans den sport wirklich zerstört
aber genau das und viele weitere fragen
habe ich ihn gefragt er jahrelang
sportwetten süchtig war riesigen
schuldenberg angehäuft hat über den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
kommt ihr zudem zwei kanal wo er in 30
minuten interview mit ihm findet das im
besten fall einigen von euch hilft das
euch vielleicht dabei hilft damit erst
gar nicht anzufangen oder dass ich
einfach informationen gibt wie scheiße
das ganze ausgehen kann also check den
ersten link in der video beschreibung
kommt auf meine zweikanal shack team aus
wirklich absoluter irgendwann das nicht
vorbei gekommen ist und mir gesprochen
hat es war sehr aufschlussreich und es
war wirklich krass seine geschichte zu
sein
ey what the [ __ ] ich sehe meine 200 euro
spenden ja wirklich perfekt auf und ab
der gefühle
kein problem ps noch aber die können
jetzt macht die scheichs oder reinalter
hayward de facto ja die haben bock jetzt
erst jetzt spielen ab die chance des
jahres das war wie verliert man 245 euro
innerhalb von zwei stunden aber was
genau hat jetzt an diesem abend mit
dieser wette nicht geklappt ich hatte
auch per se gegen saint-etienne gesetz
per se eines der teuersten teams
weltweit mit über 800 millionen euro
team wert fast zehn mal so viel wert wie
saint etienne und trotzdem haben die nur
1 1 gespielt was bedeutet dass meine
wette nicht durchgegangen ist ein
deutlich größeres team ein komplett
neuer trainer bei paris und trotzdem
funktioniert das nicht es ist eben
glücksspiel es bleibt mitspielt egal wie
gut die teams sind es kann alles
passieren das kann alles passieren aber
dazu mehr
am letzten tag den wir jetzt mal
standhaft verloren haben werden wir
heute hoffentlich wieder einen dicken
holen einen fetten fisch an land ziehen
und so unser konto auf stoppen ich habe
mich ein bisschen um geschaut und
gesehen dass bayern heute abend spielt
bayern hat am ersten tag mehr sehr viel
glück gebracht und das ding mit fünf
toren extra baum noch gedreht ich glaube
diesen wirklich eine absolute ausnahme
mannschaft zerstören eigentlich alles
was da ist und wenn man nicht gerade
super viel pech hat und das eine aus 100
spielen trifft wo sie mal nicht gewinnen
dann ist das eigentlich eine safe wette
einfach wirklich in der safer wette
absolute ausnahme mannschaft deswegen
habe ich mich ein tag vor ende des
projektes entschieden kurzfristig all in
auf bayern heute abend gegen
mönchengladbach zu setzen sieht bayern
ist eine 1,57 quote das bedeutet wenn
wir 5 169 euro um 76 cent rein tun haben
wir einen gewinn von 894 euro und 52
cent beziehungsweise einen umsatz von
894 euro
das ganze wäre extrem saftig und dann
könnten wir morgen bei den letzten
bundesligaspielen die wir noch mitnehmen
können
noch mal ein bisschen was machen und
aber so vielleicht schon mal sicher
gehen dass wir mit plus aus diesem
projekt ausgehen dafür muss bayern heute
abend allerdings gewinnen ich schicke
die wette ab ihr seht es oben rechts ich
habe null euro in meinem bankkonto und
mache das alles von diesem einen spiel
abhängig ist das schlau ich weiß es
nicht es ist dumm jawohl 20 die spielen
so fucking gut alter selbst ich komplett
ohne ahnung sehe dass die so fucking
viel besser sind als mönchengladbach so
schnell verlieren wir den vorsprung
mein gott drei zu zwei meine 500 euro
spenden vor mir ich brauche zwei tore
von bayern damit ich mein geld nicht
komplett verloren hat das bringt gar
nichts mehr das projekt endet
anscheinend hier ich habe bis auf den
letzten cent alles gesetzt und das ist
der größte horror das ist die größte
chance die ich jemals gemacht habe
gladbach gewinnt nach 0 2 rückstand
gegen den fc bayern münchen freude auf
seiten von marco rose und coop und
kinder
genau das ist der grund warum ihr keine
sportwetten betreiben sollte um 690 euro
haben mich diese sportwetten erleichtert
das ist der grösste hass das war wie
viel geld kann man innerhalb von einer
woche mit sportwetten gewinnen
beziehungsweise in meinem fall verlieren
vielleicht komme ich ja mit diesem video
dem ein oder anderen die augen öffnen
egal ob ich schon spielt oder ob jemand
überlegt habe irgendwas zu tippen ich
rate euch ist einfach komplett sein zu
lassen selbst der eine euro den verliert
der lohnt sich nicht ich glaube wirklich
dass einfach niemand davor sicher ist
bei sportwetten oder allgemeinen
glücksspielen sucht wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich selber einen
daumen nach oben freuen vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren damit ihr kein
video mehr verpasst wir sehen uns
nächste woche sonntag macht es gut ich
wünsche euch einen wunderbaren tag